Hey, David, what do you think the legacy
of Donald Trump will be? These questions
are tough because it really you need time to
pass to be able to say, but if the George W.
Bush presidency is any indication, sometimes you
can tell pretty quickly, what do I mean by that?
When George W. Bush left office, my belief was his
legacy would be squandering the goodwill that came
after 9/11 by invading the wrong country, Iraq, in
response to the 9/11 attacks and then dramatically
escalating domestic surveillance and privacy
incursions with the Patriot Act, etc.. That's what
if you said on Obama's day one, what is George
W. Bush's legacy going to be? I would have said
that it was that. And that is essentially what.
George W. Bush's legacy has been so sometimes
you can tell right away, if you asked me today,
what will Trump's legacy be, I think it will be
Trump as the ultimate buffoon who mishandled covid
and ruined relationships around the world. Even
the ruined relationships around the world may
fade as Joe Biden restores those relationships.
But really, the covid failure, inciting a riot,
being impeached twice and being sort of a buffoon
strike me as what are most likely to be Donald
Trump's legacies. When people talk about
a president, the first thing you often go to is
what were the big failures with George W. Bush?
It was you invaded the wrong country after
9/11. That sticks. That's legislation aside.
Tax cuts, OK? Yeah, Bush did a little bit of tax
cutting and then taxes went up a little under
Obama and down a little bit under Donald Trump.
I don't think that's going to be the stuff of
legacies. Trump would like the wall to be his
legacy. He just didn't build it. Claiming to
have built it doesn't make you doesn't make
it a legacy. If he didn't actually do it.
Unless you can trick a lot of people when
you think about what is Trump's big failure,
my mind goes to his complete and total failure
of handling and of leadership around coronavirus
the capital attack because it's not even a
failure. It's actually a misdeed. He incited
the riots at the capital that will be there. And
then I do think from a demeanor standpoint, being
this buffoon so easily triggered the thinnest
skinned president we've maybe ever had, who,
you know, was enamored with authoritarians and
ruined relationships with our historical allies.
And then in pop culture, it seems that he will be
sort of seen as a Nixon type for a little while,
except Trump impeached twice rather than Nixon
who resigned. He'll be sort of the butt of jokes
and the the go to the meme
of the delusional, dumb,
corrupt president. But over time, we will
see those are my instincts. And he will be
seen as a one term president who accomplished
nothing in terms of solid legislation
and who who did some really horrible things.
Now, what you know, what about Barack Obama?
What is it? What is Barack Obama's legacy? I'm
curious to hear from you. For me, Obama's legacy
is Obamacare president during the legalization
of gay marriage and unfortunately, scaling up
drone warfare. That's what I think about when
I think about Barack Obama. And unfortunately,
when you do three bullet points, you miss a
lot. I mean, you what the intangible value
of Barack Obama making the U.S. more respected
around the world than it had been in a long time
compared to Donald Trump making the US. Tragically
not respected around the world. That's more of an
intangible that's hard to put on a list, but
I do think that under Barack Obama that that
certainly was one of the important things. But
does that show up on a bullet pointed list? Now
it's Obamacare at the top. Drone warfare. Tell me
what else what else would be under Obama's legacy?
Those are my thoughts right now. Let me know
your answer to the primary question, which is
what will the legacy be of Donald Trump? We
have a fantastic bonus show for you today.
Get instant access by becoming a member at Join
Pakman Dotcom. If you want, you can use the coupon
code better 21 to save a huge amount.
I won't even tell you how much
better. Twenty one is the coupon
code. We'll see you on the bonus show.